turkey's foreign minister says he is
here to enhance ties with beirut and
mevlo
glo offered to help tackle lebanon's
worst crisis with its long-time partners
gulf states but that's a tough task
saudi arabia the uae bahrain and kuwait
have severed diplomatic relations with
the lebanese government because they say
it's controlled by the iranian-backed
hezbollah
we hope this crisis can be solved
through mutual respect and dialogue we
are ready to play a role in this
riyadh says the crisis is about what it
calls hezbollah's domination over the
country
the problem is not related it's not only
a lebanese one it's not a local issue
just between lebanon and saudi arabia
it's between iran and saudi arabia
chavez oglo was in tehran before
arriving in beirut which is among the
battlegrounds where the regional rivalry
between saudi arabia and iran plays out
it's also being fought in yemen where
the pro-iranian houthis are making their
way into mareb the government's last
stronghold in the north
saudi arabia is directly
accusing hezbollah of supporting the
houses that are jeopardizing the very
security of
the saudi arabia while
the united states
they
want to guarantee the minimum stability
in
lebanon
it seems the u.s and saudi arabia have
different priorities washington backs
prime minister najib's government and
has called on gulf countries to restore
ties with lebanon that needs
international support
saudi arabia has long channeled funds
into this country's fragile economy but
it has withheld support in recent years
because of hezbollah's influence gulf
arab states are a lifeline for hundreds
of thousands of lebanese and lebanon's
leaders are trying to find a way out of
the diplomatic rift which has worsened
political divisions and added to the
economic turmoil
the crisis is rooted beyond lebanon's
borders in geopolitical rivalry between
many stakeholders turkey appears to have
entered the fray senator al jazeera
beirut